a just cause is something a lot more
idealistic it's a statement of the world
that you wish that the the way the world
what you wished it worked the the world
that you imagine like we imagine a world
as pwc we imagine a world in which
and then we devote our practice we
devote our energy we devote our
resources to advance towards that cause
and we're going to bring our clients
with us the work that we do takes us
closer to that call so i'll give you an
example so my just cause our
organizations just cause we imagine a
world so you can see there's that
forward thinking which as an aside which
is why we call it
vision is because you have to be able to
see it right so we imagine a world
in which the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day fulfilled by the work that they do
that is our cause and as a cause so just
that we would be willing to sacrifice in
order to advance closer towards that
ideal we will never get there it isn't
ideal
and you can look at organizations or
leaders that have made profound impact
in their industries or in the world
you'll see these just causes whether
it's all men are created equal
right it's a just cause imperfect in all
in its own way but you can see a nation
striving
um i have a dream literally imagining
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children imperfect in its own
in in reality but you can see a nation
striving
when apple and steve jobs
used to talk about empowering
individuals to stand up to big brother
you can see the attraction to the
personal computer because it literally
gives power to an individual to compete
against a corporation imperfect but a
striving
and all of these things become striving
that become incredibly inspiring for for
a workforce because they feel like
they're contributing to something bigger
than themselves but when you think about
innovation
if you say provide greater value for our
clients
and it's not wrong i have to stress it's
not wrong
but but but when you say innovate around
that
the innovation tends to be more features
and benefits it tends to be tweaking and
efficiencies
when you say be the best i don't even
know how you innovate around that right
you can't say some to say somebody
you know
make innovate so but when you say
innovate a way to advance this the ideas
can come from anywhere inside the
organization and the ideas tend to be a
lot bigger okay so it's not that those
things are wrong
what i'm what i'm offering are
what um
a clearer path to embracing an infinite
mindset okay right it's not that the
other doesn't work it doesn't have value
it just has less value in the infinite
game